[Applause]
hot take ready hot take start it off
with a super
cake hot take ready yup
snl killed it really hot take right now
wow snl killed i have a theory i want to
know what you guys think about dogecoin
right no
it's death death of dogecoin caused by
snl
uh no no no as snl so bad and many
people lose faith
this guy can't feel anything okay my
tesla stock is down
oh is it really i don't know all i'm
saying is this
this is my theory about snl one you got
to give it up
for the gravity that they created this
was the purpose of this show i mean i
guess the purpose of the show is for
sketch comedy but like the purpose of
the show was like yo the entire world
can watch as this person that we all
care about
goes and tries to be funny and will take
certain you know off certain hot takes
about the world etc
yeah and ideally everybody's supposed to
go there and watch they're supposed to
get these hote
these hosts that are going to compel
people to watch and they did that this
time
i've never in my life before this
maybe for eddie murphy and i don't even
know if i watched any of the sketches
with eddie murphy
i maybe looked at the uh was it the
opening monologue or something like that
because i was like is he gonna do some
stand-up what's gonna be
but outside it i cared i got off stage i
was like okay let's see was he funny
let me see a sketch like how was it i
was looking for people's reactions
and i watched a couple of sketches um
and i thought they were pretty funny i
watched the chad one
where like he saves mars with pete
davidson i thought it was funny i saw a
gen z hospital did you guys see that
density hospital was good it was just
long
yeah but the idea was kind of funny it
was just you know old people using like
young people slang i get it
but uh but there were some moments that
were funny um
and i realized what i realized what they
did and i don't know if they did this on
purpose or not
but what they should continue to do is
the best people to host snl
are unfunny people when you put a funny
person as the host of snl
the expectation goes through the roof
yes you're funny you're going to make me
laugh today
i can't wait till i'm going to die
laughing and then
they go host snl which is not really
that funny
yeah and they let you down yeah when you
take someone who's basically a robot
like elon right yeah
he has a sense of humor humor clearly
you see him on twitter you see him
you know posting kind of the memes and
playing into mean culture and also like
trolling other billionaires it is fun
but not known as like one of the most
hilarious people at all
at all uh and not trying to be no uh
and then you put him in a position where
you're like well let's see if this guy's
gonna be
funny expectations are the key to
happiness the expectations are super low
they're like there's no way this guy
could be funny and then he makes you
laugh once you're like oh [ __ ] here we
go
yeah it's it's kind of more interesting
as a comedic experiment
yeah get bezos get famous people that we
do not expect to be funny and have them
host the show and see if your writers
are good enough to make them funny it's
like a chef
making a turnip delicious yeah take the
things that aren't funny and make them
funny what do we do fundamentally yeah
we take the topics that aren't funny
right try to find the hero and we try to
find the humor in it in humor i i think
that they did i saw a few of the
sketches i didn't see the whole thing
yeah but i saw it it was funny he was
kind of charming oh he was i thought
even in that sketch i was very impressed
because like you said the bar was low
for elon yes
now i don't know that the bar was
necessarily lowered for the show
because they've been laying about elon
so if i'm gonna [ __ ] on elon i better
bring the [ __ ] ruckus when it's my
turn yeah
and this uh well we had a different take
because i never wish
snl was canceled more in my life than i
did watching the tweets around the show
that's when i was reminded how annoying
everything about this show has become
where even that gen z hospital sketch
they managed to offend people because
people were saying this isn't
gen z slang this is just
african-american vernacular english or
whatever the term is now
and they're just they're calling that
gen z and that's not wrong
all kind of annoying but then what
really got me is elon musk said i'm the
first person with asperger's to host snl
a bunch of people who you normally think
would support such a thing were like
you're not first
dan aykroyd was first elon musk is only
good for bob
and it's like you guys are the [ __ ]
worst yeah
i want snl cancelled i don't want to
deal with it anymore yeah i don't want
to hear
the [ __ ] castmates complaining about
the only good thing that's happened to
the show in decades
yeah i don't want to hear the audiences
complaining that somebody isn't the
first [ __ ] on the show like i'm good
with all of it
i'm good on all of it bro just go away
which vaccine do i have to take to make
sure my kid has aspergers
if one of the if johnson johnson came
back they're like yo your kid is
guaranteed to have asperger's if you
take this
i'm plugging it up that's a selfless
parent son asperger's is the key to
success
time is it an advantage every person we
know at asperger's is successful you're
an x-man
you're a [ __ ] x-men yeah and at
least x-men well actually they did kind
of get into the victimhood [ __ ] like oh
they're after us
disappear do what you do you got
superpowers why are you acting like old
[ __ ]
professor x is kind of a [ __ ] really
cook kind of a [ __ ]
he could move every object except his
legs [ __ ] could move
everything but his [ __ ] legs dude
that's the most paralyzed
the dude could literally get you to walk
away from him if he wanted to look the
other way so he could sneak into
something
he's just like playing the victim he
couldn't move his legs he was so
addicted victim
he made himself a paraplegic yeah oh my
god bruh
cook yeah useless leg liberal cup
you know come on twizzle little legs
twizzle their legs
this [ __ ] guy professor x
this is unbelievable so yeah this is an
advantage we got to stop acting like
people with asperger's
chris rock has asperger's bill gates got
asperger's mark zuckerberg got asperger
name a billionaire that don't have
[ __ ] ass burgers
steve jobs guaranteed that 100 percent
he was an ass
burger dog oh burger yeah apparently
isaac newton had asperger's isaac no
how did they know that i don't know no
way this [ __ ] didn't even exist
though he yeah yeah yeah at what point
time
do we just admit it smart jews have
asperger's at one point
do we just come out and say it that's
their superpower
yeah how do i get ass burgers now bro
son it's the best you ignore your wife
all day just go to work and be like what
i have asperger's i guess
i'm sorry you don't have any emotional
reaction i don't yeah all right
that is life this is what it is it's
unbelievable and
my only problem is my only problem with
it is we're not gonna feel bad for them
for their advantage in life okay
yeah i'm not going to feel bad that
lebron is the most amazing athlete
in history yeah you're not going to act
like a victim because of it you know i'm
sorry i'm
six nine my fast twitch fibers are
amazing yeah i can jump out the gym
i have unbelievable hand-eye
coordination i'm one of the greatest
pastors ever i'm not gonna feel bad for
you because of that
so we gotta start taking asperger's and
looking at it as a huge
advantage you're lebrane james
because you're exceptional what you do
and a victim
hey yeah that was good
and i wish you would get off twitter
fast
so yeah so aspergers is lit how do you
know you don't have asperger's
i hope i do how would you be a little
ass burger you might think i'm ass
burgers
all right give me asperger test okay uh
let me look it up
give me one give me an asperger test
give me an asperger test this is
fire dog yeah i'm [ __ ] nervous right
now because if i don't have asperger's
oh man
that's gonna be such a letdown dude i
have to do all this with hard work
i know that should be the mensa test
it's just an asperger test
son how many mentals you think got
asperger's that's the asperger coalition
right yeah that's all it is it's a gang
of [ __ ] burgers out here
yeah i mean gb out here solve the math
problems nerds all right so we got a
couple basic asperger's okay give me an
asperger question go uh do you pursue
friendships but is it socially awkward
and you don't know what to do to
maintain the interaction
rarely sometimes never very often no
that's everybody
no i don't who doesn't pursue
friendships and sometimes who don't want
friendships and sometimes it's awkward
that's everybody
a little ass burger oh i was saying that
doesn't happen to me you never feel
awkward
with no pursuing friendships like trying
to make new friendships who makes new
friends i'm 37 years old
all right the [ __ ] just happens that's
one thing you know new friends that's
one burger that's one friends when you
get older
they got a whole asperger's anthem no
new friends no new friends
no that is a stupid one because maybe
when i was younger that was the case but
as an adult i'm not looking for new
friends they just kind of
exist it's like a mold like do you know
what i mean if you're just left out long
enough then you get some mulch
right that's what friends are when
you're older but go on all right so
that's one burger for you i think yeah
wait do i have a burger or no you have
one burger i think i thought i answered
it wrong you said you don't make any
friends
that's that's 37. who's making five
questions say what you grew into your
burger
i grew into my burger yes i'm just going
with it
i'm just going with it let's go does
your child have difficulty during
okay not your child this is for kids
okay uh do you have difficulty during
social interactions like monopolizing
conversations
you don't pick up on social cues bossy
etc
i don't know what you're talking about
[Laughter]
i don't know what you're talking about
like that
listen you might think i got burgers i
got impossible meat over here because
that could not be
that could not be further i can't
believe it's not burgers yeah
real talk now that might be big i got
one burger right there
on burgers bro yeah yeah what's beyond
burger just give me the prime rib dog
you're born full steak ain't no mince
meat over here
i'm the filet mignon of this [ __ ]
all right if the fillet autism okay keep
going
that's another thing stop separated from
autism right it's on respect no no
that that is wrong no it's not it's like
blender for autism
remove autism entirely from it
yeah i understand that's how they try to
sell it to us because they want to be
[ __ ] a little bit so you can't make
fun of
like that [ __ ] went on right
before we were about to make fun of him
for being on snl he was like yo i'm
[ __ ] and like nah i can't make fun
of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you can't be [ __ ] and you're the
richest person in the world that's true
what the [ __ ] that makes me that's true
if you're [ __ ] that's true what am i
that's true
son i am the what is the [ __ ] of
[ __ ]
that's what do you call the [ __ ]
kids that you're like
man this [ __ ] don't even like
ice cream bro like how [ __ ] is he
i think it's a double negative i think
everything two retards make a
make a elon musk an elon musk okay
that's possible all i'm trying to say is
let's remove
asperger's from that spectrum it's
autism and then we take asperger's we
put it over here that's that's
and what is it what is asperger's on
it's like a different spectrum it's a
superb thing it's a superpower
superpower sexuality as well the whole
thing so it's like height
keep on going okay uh do you uh exhibit
repetitive or robotic speech
yeah all the time okay so that's two
burgers um
do you struggle or or what is it robotic
speech
yeah yeah i mean you just repeated it
right there yeah i definitely have
autism no this is not autism this is
asperger's autism is whack
uh do you struggle to understand
non-verbal communication despite having
good verbal skills
no okay that's true he's right do you
engage in awkward mannerisms or
repetitive movements such as hand
flapping or
toe walking for example no but that
annoys the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me so
you're a self-loathing burger the toe
walking
drives me out and i didn't know that
those people
were actually [ __ ] i thought that
they were making a choice to walk on
their toes like that
and it would drive me crazy and i
remember in high school i would put my
hands on their shoulders and
hold them down when they would i would
hold them down yeah no
it's infuriating why is it so
infuriating
they're bouncing around for no reason
unnecessarily that would be effects
unless they want to go to space why do
you think anyone's building a rocket
that's a good point that's a good point
there you go
i mean it's not really a good point but
it was a good joke that's a good joke to
be made in that moment
all right do you obsess over topics
interests or fears yes
yeah all right do you have difficult
questions who doesn't obsess over topics
interest or fears
regular people bro yeah i just want to
be rags
you'd have difficulty maintaining eye
contact no no
do you have difficulty maintaining a
back and forth on time sometimes i do
have
difficulty making eye contact like with
benue this weekend with his body bro
ben wieda was was with us in phoenix
this weekend and he was taking his shirt
off and going into the ball oh
[ __ ] i couldn't trick her treat bro
a high calorie treat in the pool coming
out oh
bro it was bad that [ __ ] was
just sitting on top of the pool and then
mark
and miles are looking at them and they
just plunk their body inside the water
because they just could not be
seen next to that [ __ ] goose
yeah he's a little fortune cookie that
guy
um all right do you have that was racist
was that racist that was racist why is
that racist
that was that racist i just said he's
like a little internment camp with that
guy that's a little
snack that's a different asian bro get
your asians right it's not any asian bro
it's an american snack
no it's not yes it is no it's not is it
no it's not yes it is no it's not is
that repetitive
repetitive speech you're making me my
ass burger
burger you're making me the hamburger
right now you're wonderful
you're welcome you're welcome let's go
all right do you have difficulty
maintaining
[ __ ] are aspergers
time exactly this is good so ask listen
i guess what there's one more question
to find out if you're fully burned down
what is that you just can't finish the
test have you been able to finish this
test
listen as burger your boy's ass burger
dog no aspergers are the jews
and then hamburgers are not just
hamburgers
okay all right do you repeat lines from
shows and movies in repetitive fashion
no i feel like you do i don't
who does that bro you say movie lines
all the time you don't watch movies you
wouldn't know what the lines were yeah
that's
that's the thing you see actually you
would never know with the step brothers
and all the time remember oh don't do
that to me you do
don't do that i'm not one of those what
movie is that from don't do that to me
yeah me myself and irene
don't do that to me me and myself was
like smoking
isn't that jim carrey yeah [ __ ] goat
all right we go all right so we have
your score here
all right what'd i get ow do you want to
read the results no you got it
moderate indication of asperger's
syndrome that's exactly what he said
congrats dude god damn i can't even be
good at asperger's brother what the
[ __ ] now you're a moderate bird bruh i
got a modern burger
yeah damn all right that's lit you're a
little junior bacon yeah
junior whopper oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] i'm so
excited yeah you're doing it
i'm allowed to feel things yeah yeah i'm
really excited
i'm like i have a high emotional
i have a high emotional reaction that's
how i'll react to stuff
[Laughter]
the only thing separating you from full
burger is al's left is this we had owl's
laugh you full burger oh that laugh is
burnt
yeah if you were white with that laugh
that's a burger
burger you do have a longer leash as a
black person with your weird laugh but a
white person that would just go
[Laughter]
dude that's not even burger that's full
reread
i want to say it but it is right you're
the burger king with that one brother
that laugh could support the farmers
that react
all right man so what are you guys
thoughts on the uh snl
uh well yeah what did you would you in
general did you first of all did you
guys watch any sketches before you react
i watched the gen z sketch and i watched
the monologue
okay and i thought the gen z sketch was
like
like conceptually funny didn't really go
anywhere
like it was just them playing right
that's how i felt about it
whenever i watched the californians yeah
it felt the exact same as that where
it's like
i guess you guys are laughing but i
don't it's the same joke over and over
again but like if it was just quick you
just make that 30 seconds
that's the thing i give a ton of leeway
to snl in general just because it's so
hard to make
an hour or however long the show is an
hour and a half yeah an hour and a half
of like
comedy every week like that's like an
impossible task in general
i don't give them that leeway because
they choose to do it yeah just make it
half hour and make it hot and then
everything will be fine
that's true you said you enjoyed it
right on a one to ten scale
just what i saw i just saw i thought
three sketches
and then the uh uh his part of the
weekend update
okay and the majority of the show no i
thought it was an hour and a half i
watched probably
then there's music seven minutes
commercials like you get about maybe
seven sketches two music performances
that's about the show
wow okay so i did watch part of the
weekend update yeah and
i was charmed by him i thought it was
cool to see somebody who is so composed
brilliant and successful
be vulnerable and it's like a really
humble thing to do is to go out there
and know you're gonna look
stupid and he was gonna look stupid at
certain points in time and i
really respected that i just thought it
was really [ __ ] cool
to be willing to be i don't know that
hmm egoless now is that intrinsic to
like the entrepreneurial gene
you know what i mean like this is a guy
that's like put yourself in this
situation to build an occupant
explode on like land oh i'm gonna fail
i'm gonna build a car company even
though every car coming in history has
been i thought it was just
an asperger thing where he's like hey
even if i look stupid we'll make money
kind of like we said last week maybe you
said it last week specifically but like
yeah i'm gonna look stupid but we're
gonna make money and we're gonna get uh
publicity and it's gonna benefit me in
the long run
i'll look stupid who cares maybe maybe
but it felt like you were going
somewhere with that just my theory is
that i think
you would enjoy watching snl on a
regular basis because well for
the sketches i've seen that was an
average episode of esoter
so i think all the snl hate you got to
take it back but
but clearly you haven't been listening
for the last month no yeah
clearly you don't pay attention what
i've always said about snl is i can't
criticize it because i don't watch it i
can't criticize it no i don't
we actually we actually [ __ ] on we're
like why are comics still [ __ ] on it
which i get why but
literally the last time i was become
kind of a hat it's become a trope it's
like
i i remembered why when i saw the tweets
around it this weekend
but it's like a lot of comments who are
upset where they are in their career and
they just take it out on snl because
they know they're not going to be on snl
so it's a safe thing to criticize
gotcha but i i say i cannot act
accurately say if this show is good or
not because
i don't watch a show what i do see of
the show
i'm often not impressed also your
hypocrites so
yeah but that's also another thing but
but that's what i've said always on the
podcast what i have seen the show i'm
often not impressed by it
but this was impressive to me because i
was charmed by elon
and i thought the sketch was okay but
i'm going into it going
with the lowest expectations i should go
into this legacy television show with
the highest right
like if i go watch if i go watch a chris
rock special if i watch a dave chappelle
special if i watch a patrice o'neill
special
i'm going in going this is the greatest
this
you got it's right here you got to beat
this with snl for whatever reason this
is the longest running comedy show on
television
in history and i go in going this is not
going to make me laugh
that's a problem especially since i know
people on the show
who are really funny on stage yeah like
really funny on stage
and not that funny on the show so i'm
just like who's still a stand-up on that
show
oh she's a writer
sam is so [ __ ] funny i mean michael
che it's kind of icelandic
he's doing his own thing now he's got
his show that's good i'm excited to see
that
yeah i've watched the first episode very
creative well done so like i know people
who
write on the show or on the show and on
stage are [ __ ] beasts
yeah and then that doesn't get displayed
on tv so i'm like there's something
there's a mechanism also
yes there's a governor like you know in
a car like the car says it goes 220 but
you push it it only goes 160. yeah
that's snl
it got a governor and the governor's
probably antiquated like
it's they're probably working off these
fcc rules from 40 years ago
and it's like we've moved past it like
we can hear certain bad words we can
have certain opinions that are a little
bit crazy now here's a fun question if
you took the whole cast
the whole production the whole budget
yeah and put it on youtube yeah do you
think the show would be better yes
like without those governors fcc rules
tv i think anything
will be better without those governors i
do believe that sincerely
i think anything will be better without
limitation
um some people often say like limitation
uh
forces you to be more creative yeah you
know but i don't really believe that
because i think that your like
creativity is inspired by who you are as
a person so
i don't think people are gonna go well
since i'm free to do whatever i want i
don't need to be creative now
you're just gonna be that much more
creative you already have natural
limitations just by who you are
you don't need more exactly so why would
you govern your creativity in any way
and uh i mean i would love to see them
do it i really would
like it'd be really cool to see just a
few of like the people from that show
maybe when they're done
just like do a version of it for for
youtube or version for facebook or
something like that
you